now adari was a firsthand account of
jewish life in hiding during the second
world war now three-quarters of a
century after the death of anne frank a
new investigation has identified a
suspect who may have betrayed her family
to the nazis while anne frank and her
family spent 761 days over two years
hidden behind a bookcase in a house in
amsterdam they were captured on the
morning of the 4th of august 1944
probably after the location was handed
to the nazis by arnold van der beau a
jewish man who it's thought gave up the
franks to save his own loved ones they
were sent to auschwitz a month later and
her sisters were then moved to
bergen-belsen a concentration camp in
norman northern germany where they
contracted typhus and died in february
1945
and was just 15 years old
well joining me now is the retired fbi
special agent vince pankow who's
director of investigation for the anne
frank cold case um
if it's just tell us about this this new
research how were you able to find this
new link to arnold van der beau
well surprisingly the link was there all
along it was just like in many cold
cases an overlooked clue detail that we
found
in the report of the
1963-64 investigator
and and why was it not spotted that this
link could be more significant
well in in the report itself the
investigator said that he looked into
this allegation of a note that otto
frank told him about
and that
through assimilated intelligence he
realized that
the
character of arnold vandenberg was
beyond reproach and he just dropped it
but how do you believe now that that he
was potentially the man who gave up the
location of where they were all hiding
well in the report otto frank
informed the detective that shortly
after liberation he received a note that
identified arnold vandenberg as the
betrayer
when we did our research we found out
arnold vandenberg was in the jewish
council we knew the jewish council was
abolished in september of 43 and so we
figured the the substance of the note
couldn't be true but of course we found
out that arnold vandenberg was in hiding
in plain sight he had a series of
purchased protections
from
deportation and when those expired he
had lists of addresses not names but
addresses
where jews were thought to be in hiding
which he passed to keep his safety and
his freedom
and do you believe that otto frank and
frank's father knew
who it was
well of course otto was the one who
received the note and i think that he
knew the name he even took steps in 1945
by confronting one of the dutch
detectives who participated in the raid
with the name of arnold vandenberg
so
yes now whether or not at that point he
actually believes beyond reasonable
doubt that that vandenberg was
responsible we're not sure that he did
take steps to investigate him though
and of course the family were so very
close weren't they they were so very
close to freedom at that time
yeah that i just was talking to a
gentleman who experienced world war ii
uh yesterday and said that the picture
of otto frank
watching the map
of normandy and in that part of europe
where they were almost liberated by the
allies would have been just such a tease
such a roller coaster of emotion
indeed why is it important now
to to to find out who this person was
and why they did it do you think
well i think we owe it to the memory of
the victims of the annex of the
survivors of the holocaust and the
victims of the holocaust to let them
know that you know there we haven't
forgot about them and to take a bigger
message from this that
this type of action could still happen
today once we start to tear at the
fabric of society eventually that
garment starts to fall apart
and it's important for people to realize
that uh you know even a cultured a
modernized country like germany in the
1930s fell prey to this and almost
dominated the world
we talked a little bit about our arnold
van der berg and and his motivation for
doing this your
is your supposition that he he didn't do
it to necessarily betray the family but
he did it because he felt it was
the one thing he could do to save his
own
yes there's no direct evidence that
indicates that arnold vandenberg even
knew the franks but he had lists of
addresses
impersonal lists of addresses where jews
were thought to be in hiding that he
transmitted to the sd
um we tell people to make sure not to
make the mistake of judging arnold
vandenberg or any of the other jews that
were forced into collaboration the
people to blame here are the nazi
occupiers and without for that
we wouldn't be even talking about this
today
and it does now complete something of a
story doesn't it of wartime amsterdam
we are still learning all the time
about things that happened during this
era which is astonishing really isn't it
that there's still so much to be
uncovered
when you think about how much time has
passed since world war ii which of
course my father was a veteran of the
war in europe
and that there is still new information
coming out documents like the one that
we found
that was in the papers of the
detective who had passed away years ago
it's astonishing there's still stories
out there to be told
astonishing and and also very gloomy uh
vince pankow really interesting to talk
to you very very much thanks a lot for
joining us today
thank you